If you want to hear about the true meaning
of Us and what everything represents then
stick around to the end of this video.
Jordan Peele’s Us deals with a subterranean
society of doppelgangers who rises up to take
their place in the sunlight.
The concept of literal underground societies
has been creepy and fascinating to me ever
since I found out that these so called “mole
people” actually exist.
Yeah, this is a real thing -- and Peele’s
pairing of that with another creepy concept:
doppelgangers, is bound to leave moviegoers
looking something like this.
The movie opens with a text card, telling
of the 1000s of miles of tunnels, unused subway
systems, service tunnels and mine shafts,
with no known purpose.
The first image we see is the main character,
Addie, watching TV as a young girl in 1986.
She’s watching the channel 11 news, one
of the many references to the number 11 seen
throughout the move.
We’ll come back to the meaning of 11 later
on.
First, there are some easter eggs.
On the side of the TV there are some VHS tapes,
and they may be there to honor some of the
films that helped inspire Us.
One of them is C.H.U.D, a 1984 movie about
these subterranean monsters who abduct people.
The relevance of that one should be pretty
obvious.
“And unlikely to bring anyone down there,
so they’re coming up.
C.H.U.D!”
There’s also a tape of The Goonies, a 1985
kids film in which a group of children must
search for a pirates treasure in an underground
cavern -- just as the mother in Us must venture
underground to find her abducted son.
The last tape I could make out was The Right
Stuff, which is a non-fiction movie about
the development of the space program, I’m
guessing it’s loosely related because venturing
underground is similar to space travel in
that you are setting out into an unknown frontier.
The news on the TV goes to commercial ...and
she watches an ad for Hands Across America.
The few seconds that this commercial is on-screen
are the key to understanding this entire film.
I understood everything a little bit better
when I went home and looked up what Hands
Across America actually was and what it stood
for.
Hands across America was a charity event that
took place in 1986.
Participants would donate $10 to reserve their
spot as Americans lined up and joined hands
for 15 minutes, theoretically creating a chain
from coast to coast across the mainland United
States.
The goal of the event was to raise money and
awareness to help combat hunger and homelessness.
When Addie goes to the Santa Cruz Beach Boardwalk
with her parents as a little girl, she’s
wearing a Hands Across America shirt -- and
it becomes one of her last solid memories
of the real world when she’s abducted by
the shadow people.
At the carnival, her Dad wins her a Thriller
T-shirt, which she puts on over it.
As they explore the boardwalk, Addie sees
various carnival activities that are significant.
Her father wants to ride the roller coaster,
which he calls the Little Dipper.
(In real life it’s called the Giant Dipper).
"Do the walk, the beach boardwalk.
You can do the roller coaster you can do the
swim.
Come on everybody you can walk right in."
This is either a reference to the idea that
Addie is going to be “dipping” or descending
into this underground world -- or another
way of looking at it is that the Big Dipper
and Little Dipper are constellations and while
those above the surface can see and observe
the stars, the tunnel dwelling doppelgangers
cannot.
There are even a couple of lines throughout
the movie about the joy of being able to gaze
at the stars.
They also walk by and notice some people playing
a whack-a-mole arcade game, a visual representation
of the people on the surface knocking those
who live underground back down, forcing them
to stay there.
Before wandering off the boardwalk, Addie
sees a sign that says Jeremiah 11:11, and
this has multiple meanings.
11:11 represents two sets of doubles.
It’s also symmetrical, and it's the only
time on a digital clock that appears the exact
same in front of a mirror.
This is assuming that there are slashes through
the zeroes, as there should be.
In culture 11:11 is often considered a lucky
or magic number, and I’ll be talking more
about the references to magic throughout this
video.
But this sign specifically references Jeremiah
11:11, a biblical verse that reads: Therefore,
thus says the Lord, “Behold, I am bringing
disaster upon them that they cannot escape.
Though they cry to me, I will not listen to
them.”
And this could be seen as a religious prediction
of the bloodshed that will be brought on by
the uprising of the doppelgangers.
The last thing we see before Addie leaves
the boardwalk is her Dad playing Rock, Paper
Scissors to settle a disagreement with her
Mom.
Rock, Paper and Scissors each come back later
in the movie.
The main weapon used by the shadow people
is scissors -- but the son, Jason, uses a
large rock to defeat one of them when they
flee to their friend’s house across the
lake.
Then at the end of the movie, the fake version
of Addie uses a sharp fire poker to defeat
the original Addie who is wearing the red
jumpsuit, and holding the paper cutouts of
the people linking hands, so this is kind
of a scissors beats paper moment.
So when Addie walks off the boardwalk, she
goes from the bright lights of the carnival
to the dark beach -- and there’s also a
moment at at the end of the movie when they
are battling in the underground and they move
from the lit up part of the hallway into a
stretch where the lights are off.
The maze that Addie goes into on the beach
is called Shaman’s Vision Quest.
The tagline is “find yourself”, and Addie
literally does find another version of herself
in that maze.
I also found it interesting that it starts
raining as soon as she goes in, because only
surface dwellers can experience rain.
But if you’re a mole person and you’re
watching this, don’t feel bad, because at
least you guys don’t have buy sunscreen.
So she wanders through the mirror maze, and
mirrors are another huge motif in this movie.
The doppelgangers are mirror images of the
humans on the surface, and there are plenty
of examples of reflections as symbols for
the copies.
She goes through one part in the forest where
she sees these distorted mirrors, and that
may be tied to the fact that the son of the
underground family is distorted by the burn
marks on his face.
There are three things that happen before
she runs into the doppelganger version of
herself.
One: the lights go out; and two: all she can
see is the green exit signs reflected hundreds
of times in each mirror.
Although there appear to be many exits, in
reality, she has no way out.
And three: she hears the doppelganger version
of herself whistling.
Remember those three things, because they’ll
be important later.
And when that shadow girl does turn around
and see the original Addie, the scene cuts
away before we see her being abducted, and
the other girl switching shirts with her and
going onto the surface.
Now, I know I’m not supposed to have an
opinion, but in my opinion this would have
been more convincing if we had seen her start
running, and then it jumpcut to her doppelganger
getting back to the parents on the boardwalk
so we think, oh OK she made it back alright,
and then in the reveal at the end of the movie,
it shows the shadow Addie running after and
dragging her back in before joining the parents
at the boardwalk.
It would have made it a little bit less obvious
I think.
But instead it cuts to the shot of the rabbits
in cages, so let’s talk about the meaning
of rabbits.
Rabbits are often seen as a symbol of reproduction
because they are known to reproduce very quickly.
The people underground are reproductions of
the originals on the surface.
With scissors sometimes being seen as the
image associated with a vasectomy, the surgery
that prevents you from producing offspring.
But there’s also another idea that’s commonly
associated with rabbits: and that’s magic.
The most classic magician’s trick involves
pulling a rabbit out of a hat.
Well it just so happens that when the shadow
Addie grows up and has children, her son,
Jason, is interested in magic tricks.
He has a lot of peculiar things about him.
At the start of the movie, he wears a Jaws
shirt.
Perhaps this is because Jaws is a fellow beach-set
horror movie, but it could also have to do
with his fascination with monsters.
He wears what I think is like a werewolf mask
think throughout the entire film.
Addie also has a daughter, Zora, who’s wearing
a shirt with a rabbit on it and seems to only
be interested in texting; and a husband, Gabe,
who participates in cringe-worthy dabs and
has a love for boats that's not shared by
any other family members.
After meeting the family, we cut back to the
aftermath of Addie’s childhood boardwalk
incident and discover that the doppelganger
version of her wouldn’t speak after being
found by her parents -- who of course have
no idea it’s not the real her, and think
it’s some kind of PTSD.
She sees them meet with the doctor through
a mirror.
I think the reason that she doesn’t speak
is because when the doppels come up from underground
it takes them some time to adjust to breathing
our fresh oxygen.
She’s unable to speak properly until her
lungs have adapted to the fresh air.
That’s why when the original Addie comes
back up to try to take over the surface, she
sounds like this:
"Be careful."
There’s further proof later on, when the
family flees to the other house and Gabe’s
friend’s wife is seen screaming and laughing
in the mirror, but no sound comes out.
So as the family settles into the beach house,
there are a few pieces to note around the
house.
There’s a shot of a spider crawling on the
table under a toy spider, an early clue that
the real Addie is crawling beneath, and it’s
the fake one that is on top -- on the surface.
This imagery also connects with the song that
the doppelgangers whistle when they arrive
at the house: the itsy-bitsy spider.
She expresses that she doesn’t want to go
to the Santa Cruz Beach, not because she was
traumatized there as a child, but because
she knows that she’ll be in close proximity
to the tunnel network and she’s afraid something
could happen.
Her walls are covered with artwork of Alvin
Ailey, a known dance choreographer, and at
the end of the movie, it’s revealed that
it was her dance recital when she realized
she was in control and she could be on the
surface.
It’s as the doctor told Addie’s parents,
the best they can do for her is allow her
to draw, write and dance.
Jason enjoys playing inside the cabinet / closet.
The door automatically locks when closed,
so he props it up with a little toy ambulance
thing.
It’s literally his lifeline, and also Gabe
and Zora are saved at the end of the movie
when the come across a real ambulance and
get supplies.
Inside the closet I spotted games like Guess
Who?, Magic and Candyland.
Guess Who? is literally a game where two identical
sets of people are lined up on opposite sides,
not that different than the way this world
is setup.
Magic is obviously a part of Jason’s passion
for magic tricks, and Candy Land...
I guess there’s a version where the characters
are all rabbits…?
But I didn’t have that one as a kid.
I had this one.
The mom finds a rabbit doll in a drawer and
we see she’s affected by it, but it isn’t
entirely clear why -- it’s because it reminds
her of when she was trapped underground until
she made the switch.
So they all get in the car and go to the beach.
Zora mentions something about how she thinks
the government is putting fluoride in the
water so that the government can control us,
a flight allusion to the fact that they could
all be controlled by those living underground.
As they’re about to arrive, a dead body
is wheeled onto another ambulance, and this
guy is holding another Jeremiah 11:11 sign.
This signals the beginning of everything that
happened that day at the boardwalk repeating
itself leading up to the arrival of the “tethered”
family.
Their long shadows as they walk onto the beach
signify that the shadow people are drawing
near.
The Shaman’s Vision Quest is now Merlin’s
Forest (another magic reference).
Gabe’s friend Josh bickers with his wife,
just as Addie’s parents did on the boardwalk
all those years ago.
By the way, they have twin daughters, another
example of mirrorism.
They even have a moment where they say the
same thing at the same and then both jinx
and double jinks each other.
Just like 11:11, this is an example of a pair
of doubles.
The scene with them later at the house pays
homage to Grady twins from the Shining.
I’m pretty sure the Shining has come like
3 videos in a row now -- and it actually comes
up again later in this video.
Jason wanders off to go to the bathroom and
sees the guy T-posing, or at least that’s
what it looks like, and I think this is the
first guy to come up from underground and
start the new Hands Across America chain.
His Mom freaks out when he’s gone, because
she knows about the subterranean society and
she’s afraid that Jason could be abducted.
When they get home that evening, Gabe is watching
the Giants game and if you listen to the audio
in the background, you’ll hear the score
is tied 11-11.
Not long after, when they tell the son to
go to bed, the clock reads 11:11 PM.
There’s also a LEGO ferris wheel in the
boy’s room to reference to rides at the
Beach Boardwalk, and picture of Merlin on
his bedroom wall.
He’s also wearing a tuxedo shirt which makes
him look like a magician in uniform.
His mother gets worried when she realizes
he’s drawn a picture of the T-posing man
from the beach, because she possibly realizes
what this is.
In the bedroom, she stares into her reflection
in the window as she expresses her concerns
to Gabe.
She tells him it feels like a black cloud
is hanging over her and she feels a storm
coming, very similar to how it started raining
when Addie entered the mirror maze all those
years ago.
Then the three things that happened back then
happen again: the power goes out, all exits
are compromised and whistling can be heard
from the doppelgangers.
When we first see them, they are holding hands
like the Hands Across America commercial.
The shadow people take over the house and
explain that they basically don’t have good
lives down below and they want their time
in the sun, they want to be untethered from
the bodies of the original family.
Each character goes off and battles the shadow
version of themselves.
The struggle between the two mothers is symbolic,
because Addie forces her doppelganger into
the glass table and we see it crack, representing
the barrier between the two versions of that
character being broken.
Each character is able to fight off the other
version of them and together, they flee for
Josh’s family’s house for help, but by
the time they get there, they’ve already
been taken over by doppelgangers.
One of Josh’s last actions is telling the
virtual assistant to put on “Good Vibrations”
by The Beach Boys.
The lyrics describe Addie’s fascination
with the world on the surface.
“I love the colorful clothes she wears
And the way the sunlight plays upon her hair.
I hear the sound of a gentle word,
On the wind that lifts her perfume through
the air.”
The next verse describes shadow Addie sensing
the underground uprising.
“Close my eyes,
She’s somehow closer now.”
The other song that plays has lyrics that
are little more on the nose.
“F the police straight from the underground.”
This literally describes what happens, where
the cops are unable to help them because so
many people are attacked from underground.
After defeating the copies of the neighbors,
we get that second The Shining reference I
promised.
Jason just gets done saying something about
there being too many twins when they turn
on the news and discover these people are
supposedly coming out of the sewers.
The time is displayed on the bottom left corner
of the news overlay, it’s now 2:37 -- a
reference to Room 237 in The Shining.
The family drives away in the neighbor’s
new car and they eventually encounter Jason’s
doppelganger with the mask again.
He’s luring them into a gasolene trap.
This part is a little bit confusing, but I
think what’s happening is that the two kids,
Jason and Zora have the power to control the
red suit doppelgangers, because they are both
half shadow people themselves.
So it would appear that Jason uses this power
to walk backwards and drive his creepy doppelganger
back into the flames.
He saves his family by doing so, but it also
leads to him being kidnapped.
We also get a look at a huge group of doppelgangers
linking hands along the coast, and the T-posing
guy from before has 11:11 written on his forehead,
which predicts more trouble.
So Jason’s mother goes down into the forest
maze to try to rescue him.
Then the two versions of Addie face off underground,
I’m going to put everything together and
talk about what this movie actually means,
and what it’s trying to say.
So don’t go anywhere.
Or someone will drag you underground.
And you will never come back.
So during the final showdown, Addie explains
her three decade plan, how after she was abducted
by the mole people, she basically put together
her own Hands Across America campaign.
She explains that whoever created them was
able to duplicate their bodies, but not their
souls, which I believe is why they are violent
to the surface dwellers, cause only one of
them can inhabit that soul.
Everything they have down below is just a
crappy simulation of real real life, but in
spite of that, they are human too, they are
made up of flesh and blood just like those
on the surface and they deserve and equal
experience and should not be overlooked.
That leads into what I think Us is trying
to say as a movie.
The people on the surface represent everyday
people leading normal lives in developed countries.
Sometimes, they don’t fully appreciate what
they have.
In the scene where the shadow family breaks
into the house, Addie describes the differences
between the lives of those on the surface
and those underground.
The surface people get warm meals, while the
subterranean society has to eat cold raw rabbit.
The kids on the surface get nice toys, but
the toys underground are cold and spiky.
She also describes the differences between
the two seemingly parallel families.
She tells the story of the girl who had a
shadow, how they were connected; tethered
together.
The girl married a prince.
Although the family sees Gabe is sometimes
jealous of his friend’s car, house and boat
constantly one upping him, a family such as
the doppel family would be happy with what
he has.
She also describes how the girl in the story
gave birth to a son.
Jason is sometimes criticised for being a
bit strange and wearing a monster mask, but
the shadow girl gave birth to an actual monster
who acts like a real beast and needs to wear
a mask to cover up his scars.
The idea is to be happy with what you have
and not lose sight of the fact that there
are less fortunate people among you…
maybe even living below you.
Just as Hands Across America was organized
all those years ago -- the people living underground
revive it in a much bigger way to bring attention
to the cold, sad lives that those born underground
are subjected to by staging their own movement.
The final shot of the movie is a huge sweeping
overhead shot showing the massive amount of
people in red jumpsuits forming a Hands Across
America chain, the shot is very reminiscent
of the 1986 commercial that was shown to us
at the very beginning of the movie.
Of course, if you have another interpretation
of this movie, or any other things I might
have missed in this video, be sure to let
me know in the comments, and check out the
playlist on the left to see all the things
you might have missed in the trailers for
the upcoming horror movie Pet Sematary.
Remember to subscribe to CZsWorld for new
horrors every week, ring that deathbell for
notifications and I’ll see you in the next
one.
Assuming we both survive.